alerte coronavirus
pour vous protéger et protéger les
autres restez chez vous tout déplacement
est interdit sauf muni d'une attestation
dans les cas suivants aller travailler
si le télétravail est impossible faire
des courses de première nécessité faire
garder ses enfants ou aider des
personnes vulnérables
aller chez un professionnel de santé si
vous n'avez pas de signes de la maladie
dans tous les cas respecter un mètre de
distance avec toute personne est
appliquée systématiquement les gestes
barrière l'avez-vous très régulièrement
les mains avec du savon ou utiliser une
solution hydroalcoolique tousser ou
éternuer dans votre coude ou dans un
mouchoir utiliser des mouchoirs à usage
unique puis jetée l'est salué sans
serrer la main et arrêter les
embrassades
plus d'informations au 0 800 130 000 ou
sur gouvernement.fr ceci est un message
du ministère chargé de la santé et de
santé publique france